directly to camera uh yeah or off off a
little bit um directly to the camera
okay okay go ahead hi my name is John
Keating and I'm an actor in Los Angeles
and then let's try one where you look
the other way go ahead hi my name is
John Keating and I'm an actor in Los
Angeles my type is I look like an
average Joe character Meg westerner who
has the essence of being quiet decent
shy harmless friendly and goofy that
could be typed as an employee
conservative middle management dad or
religion nut and can be cast as a
computer technician accountant car
salesman IRS employee City Hall clerk
scientist or dentist I have an acting
coach who talks about having a quality
that he calls in Sioux shins which
apparently is a French word i'm not
familiar with it but it's almost a
carefree not care less but a carefree
attitude toward your work and whenever
I'm working and whenever I see someone
who does great work they have that
quality about them as well as in
addition to that what I strive for in my
work and what I look for in actors who
do great work is being what he also
calls a force of nature where you're
just caught up in it and you might not
even be but you be able to explain why
I'm originally from the midwest the
kansas city kansas area i moved back out
to LA in 2003 yeah I moved out here in
the late 80s in the early 90s and then
for a variety of reasons moved back to
Kansas Citian in the early 90s and took
some time off from acting and just lived
a regular workaday world life and
decided I couldn't give it up so I made
preparations to get back out here
I love Cary Grant he's my favorite actor
movie star producer I love Patrick
Stewart and his work I've always had a
soft spot in my heart for William
Shatner and he seems to have sort of a
devil-may-care attitude about what other
people think of what he's doing I think
when you're connected to your heart and
you're in the moment that's the hallmark
of a great actor and great acting
I worked through a regular nine-to-five
job for a couple of years and I realized
that I wasn't staying true to the artist
in me I've always had artistic
tendencies when I was a boy I used to
draw cartoons and I would draw from Mad
Magazine I loved the artist Mort Drucker
and I would draw him and I also loved a
in junior high and high school
performing in place and and I knew I
just loved the the applause I loved
performing and making people laugh is
one time in high school I was working at
the movie theater as an usher and behind
the concession stand and it was an after
a screening of terms of endearment I was
watching the crowd as they were filing
out as a credits were rolling and down
at the very front of the row I was in
the back of the auditorium and at the
very front of the row there was a family
who was speaking in hushed tones and
then all of a sudden they started
hugging each other and I realized what a
powerful medium filmmaking was and it
appeared to me as though this family was
brought together and actually had a
chance to glow krause grow closer
because of what they had seen in this
film and I realized I want to be able to
affect people in a positive way like
that and I realized by working my
nine-to-five job I wasn't staying true
to that so that's the main reason I
decided to come back to Hollywood
you
I'm in the minority with the support I
get from my family I my family is really
supportive of my decision to be in Los
Angeles pursuing an acting career and I
feel very lucky that I have their
support they miss me of course they
would love it if I were around but they
know that this is what I want to do and
I stay in touch with them as much as I
can but I know that I've got their
support because they know that I'm
pursuing what I love to do so I'm one of
the lucky few I've got a supportive
family who loves me and and wants me to
be the best of whatever it is that I
want to do and I feel the same way about
them and their pursuits and what they're
doing so I think I'm the exception to
the rule when it comes to families
handling rejection is an interesting
idea the way I kind of handle rejecting
rejection at least on the audition side
of dances I'm I prepare for my audition
I go in I do my best work and then when
I'm finished I let it go and that's
that's the best way to that I found to
handle my rejection in terms of
auditions and realizing that it's not me
that's being rejected it's just I for
this particular role for this particular
part I'm not that person I had a one of
my one of my favorite things to do is
personal development and one of my gurus
throughout the years it's been weighing
dire and he had a interesting philosophy
listening to one of his tape said he
talked about and he said he was on an
airplane and he was talking to the
flight attendant
and there was a delay and people were
going to be getting off the plane and
she was kind of confiding in him saying
wow I just it's so difficult when this
happens because people are going to come
off the plane and they're going to be
complaining to me and mad at me and blah
blah blah and he said well when when the
people are doing that instead of you
know taking it in just just think that
they're saying it to the uniform the
uniform that you're wearing they're not
talking to you the person they're
talking to the uniform and that you
don't have to let that get in and affect
you just let it know it's a uniform and
then when you respond to them just
respond kindly and you know wish them
well and so she said she did that and
she said it was just amazing so it's
it's it's knowing that uh if I get a no
it's not about me I don't make it about
me as a human being pursuing my art on
this implanted I try to let it be a no
to my uniform as an actor don't submit
myself on projects at this point anymore
i decided to take a break from that the
casting director Bonnie Gillespie says
you got to find your people so you know
people who got you and so a lot of what
I spend my normal routine on is meeting
people and staying in touch with them
that's that's my main focus and as
particularly in particular staying in
touch with people who I feel like are my
people one of the big differences when
it comes to success is just never giving
up I think some people make it because
they don't give up and certainly there's
a certain amount of luck or grace or
whatever but I one of the one of the
saints that gives me encouragement was
from one of my acting teachers who had a
quote that he either were sighted or
head up on his wall I don't remember
which but it basically heron Harrison
Ford said
a lot of Thea tributed a lot of his
success in the fact that he didn't give
up when a lot of his we have people who
came on the bus with him did one
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over again expecting
different results and I'm not saying the
people who do that who submit themselves
are insane because there's you know
there's millions of reasons to do that
but I'm saying for me I decided I wanted
to take a different approach I wanted to
uh you know uh because of what I what
struck a chord with me what Bonnie said
I'll find your people and also i
oftentimes go to hear people in the
industry speak and a common theme i'm
finding out from them is they're like
create your own work work with people
you love respect and and who do good
work I am definitely encouraged by my
family my friends I surround myself with
like-minded people who want to do some
of the things same things I want to do
and my religion my spirituality i I
really uh have gotten really good at
giving things to God that bothered me so
not to get too preachy or anything but I
really feel like um I've found a you
know I don't talk about a whole lot but
I really feel like I found a
relationship with my Creator and that's
huge for me it's me I never thought
about it when I was younger but I'm
finding that that is really a powerful
thing for me in addition to my family
and friends so if I feel like I'm
getting worried or or something's
bothering me you all right I'm getting
negativity in my life I just kind of
give it up to God you know and that's um
that's really how I deal it helps me
deal with some of the things that are
frustrating
I give up to God the things that are
kind of ancillary the actual pursuit
which can be frustrating I don't find it
for example when I'm doing auditions and
going about doing the things that
actually get me work I really enjoy
doing it particularly like auditioning
or performing but the things that I give
up or like worries about financial
survival or noises out on the street or
the neighbors you know what upstairs
playing things too loud um so it's a
sense of letting go of the things that
irritate me because from from the acting
that I do whether it's an audition a
role a class um there's there's nothing
that I want to give up about that but
it's just kind of the everyday being
human being sort of thing where I've got
to give it up it's like the neighbors
playing is a loud music again okay I'll
do something where I don't have to focus
on that I'll do something that I won't
make a phone call because they'll hear
it in the background and basically just
uh one thing that I do give up which I
feel is important is being too hard on
myself because I've had a tendency to do
that in the past and I really really try
to be more forgiving of me and maybe
some of the things that I don't feel
like I'm doing well and and just getting
strength from the fact that if I
continue to pursue it intelligently I'll
get better at it and it's funny because
I've had some real cool personal
revelations since I moved back to LA up
just about me as a human being and its
really
let let go of a lot of angst and it's
amazing how how much peace you can have
in your life when you let go some of
your angst the biggest joy is those
moments that I've had for example being
on that that day on the set of monuments
eos it's moments like that where you're
in the flow to quote a book title when
you're in the flow when you're when
you're really connecting and you know
you're doing what you love to do it's
still the same huge City there just
seems to be more traffic but I really
feel like it's home for me I don't see
myself moving back to Kansas I really
feel like I've established myself here I
love the city I love the weather the
people are great I would love to travel
more and I'm sure at some point I will
but calling LA home is a good thing
right now it's what I feel I really want
to do and need to do for myself hi I'm
John Keating and I'm an actor
you